how much time do you spend outlining a
story I know you had talked about a
friend that had this like really long
outline and yeah and do keep it to one
page or how do you do it um I usually do
like maybe two or three pages like I'll
do like a super rough outline and I'll
just flush out a little bit more and
then try to write the script after that
because I I find that most of the the
fun stuff comes when I'm writing so I
definitely try to have everything
planned out as far as like this is
what's gonna happen in the story and
these are the characters they're gonna
make it to the end and you know here's
when this person you know I try to plot
all that stuff out but sometimes I leave
stuff open because it's when you're
writing it all is hidden like a lot of
times you'll get inspired by some fun
stuff how do you get better at writing
was it through the notes that you got
when you think about let's say you know
being 16 and and writing something
versus now what do you think was the
main thing to really get you better at
it to really improve your craft um
I think it was just thought I think it
was reading scripts and also that which
you know you learned it from it to it
positive is that insecure feeling that
you have that you know and I know I hear
people talk about this all the time I
like actors of whatever they're always
like the way they always were to like
they're afraid that someday somebody's
gonna realize that they were a fraud and
they're not really that good you know
isn't actor writer and I think people
that get better and better or people
that have that thing and then where
they're worried you know that they're
not good enough yet so they strive
harder so that's for me it's like I
think if I ever get to the point where
I'm like oh I've this is this is the
best horror script that's ever gonna
ever be done and so I've written it and
I can just quit now then I'm screwed
because I again I meet people like that
all the time where they're like trust me
this is gonna be the best movie you'll
ever you know and it's like it's not
gonna go so maybe ever you know don't
say that like if you guys get me aids so
I think that that drive to constantly
get better and top yourself as far as
like the last thing that you did like
you know like you know final destination
I'm very proud of that because it was
kind of a because it was it was a you
know this is the first time that death
had actually been like the killer in a
film so you know we you know it was kind
of a benchmark kind of film like I'm
just trying to be nice bad but it was it
made a you know it has it definitely has
a bookmarking in horror history so
that's enough of something to make me
happy
but I want to you know with the
Lionsgate project about that to be
another bookmark as far as that was the
first you know studio release film with
a you know diverse cast and you know
it's my first slasher film too so I'm
getting back into the slide or not back
in but I'm you know hopefully will kind
of kick the new way of the slashers off
so now I actually now I have forgot the
point was they owe in terms of getting
better so it's not getting better
ya know it's it's you know I don't want
to I always joke I don't want to milk
final destination yeah I don't want that
to be my graves don't like hero final
destination that's like you know my only
thing like so I wanna I want more I want
a couple more franchises before I die so
I know to do that I have to keep writing
and I know that I don't have to write
good stuff and you know hopefully
something will stick you know
you